So now, we're ready for a quiz to see that
you understand the meaning of assignment. So the question is, what
is the value that the variable hours refers to after running
this code? And the code is below. First, we have an
assignment statement assigning the value 9 to the variable hours. Then,
we have another assignment statement where the right side is hours
plus 1 and the left side is hours. And then we
have another assignment statement where the left side is hours, and
the right side is hours times 2. So the possible answers, the value of hours is
9, the value of hours is 10, the value of hours is 18, the value of
hours is 20, the value of hours is 22, or it's an error. So try to
figure out the answer yourself without evaluating this
code in the interpreter. If you want to evaluate code
in the interpreter, though, it's certainly a good idea to try that.